it looks like the no confidence vote
against Prime Minister may it's not that
thing is dying so will she get her
withdrawal agreement through things I
think at the moment she's going to be in
great difficulty because it's not just
the fact that there is this group of
hard
ideologically driven brexit ears of the
conservative ventures that will not vote
for it there are other people on the
conservative benches who are looking at
this or even they don't like it and that
includes people like myself who are in
no doubt that the best deal that we have
is the current deal and of course the
Labour Party the other opposition
parties will also vote against it so the
moments very difficult to see how she's
going to get it through but with no deal
looming are you going to vote for an
idea there's no I think we absolutely
have to get this clear that there is no
majority either in the House of Commons
for no deal no deal is no option so
forget that the choice is actually going
to be between her deal or what I think
is increasingly the view of many people
that if she can't get it through
Parliament even if she does get it
through Parliament in nightmares it must
go back to the British people now we see
the reality of privacy and the fact that
actually we still don't know where our
final landing place will leave that's
imperative it goes better than most
people and we have this people's boat
and she's a choice between remain and
how did you see that panning out under
what circumstances what has to happen so
that you actually get the people's vote
well I think that I think that if we get
into a situation in Parliament where
there's this in us and there's no way
through it then where us are we to go
but other than back to the meetings
sorry that that is a that is a
possibility but I think most importantly
I think as the British people begin to
see the realities of privacy they
understand it in all its complexities
and its consequences which are bad for
the country they are seen that actually
the deal we have got with the European
Union which we will never be able to get
again if we need we will never be able
to get as good a deal as we know is
there but you need to understand I'll
see all of that I think there is a
desire for each being that this matter
should return to them and that's what we
seem to do to continue to make the case
we've achieved a lot in the last six
months we will keep although there's a
chance we do get this back and you are
very passionate fighting for it I mean
also get against a lot of adversity and
even threats can you can you explain
that to us oh yeah three people are
already gone to prison or if you see if
custodial prison sentences for death
threats to me and 12 members of
parliament to share my views and I had a
death threat only last week and and it
becomes almost a shrug of the shoulders
because the theatre these are serious
death threats you know the police get
involved and so on and so forth and so
same people have actually received
custodial prison sentence it was to one
person as you gone through these
appalling threats IOC's it's an
appalling state